for many of us when the lockdown began
there was nowhere to go but online the
pandemic drastically affected the way we
work and how we interact with others
changes that would have taken years have
been implemented in just days but will
we ever change back what does the crisis
tell us about the future of work so the
corona virus pandemic has had a massive
impact on the world of work it's seen
millions of people lose their jobs as
industries were obliterated and
businesses closed their doors but for
many of those lucky enough to remain
employed it's revolutionized the way
they operate the way to work is one of
the few things that hasn't changed but
for Tomas la semilla this morning is
just like starting over it's really the
first time in three months have been in
the office
I've worked from home the whole time in
the past the management consultant was
always on the go in the office or
visiting clients since the virus though
many workplaces at Anne stand young have
become restricted areas business trips
have gone online but will things stay
that way that's what he's investigating
on behalf of the German Environment
Ministry is giving a report today do you
Khulna coronavirus measures and
countermeasures have forced changes to
behavior and routine that many people
find positive that's why things will
stay that way permanently in the long
term according to his study the number
of business trips will probably decrease
by 30 percent compared to the time
before the pandemic and traffic in
general by at least 8 percent when the
lockdown began in March
Germany experienced a forced
digitalization that would otherwise have
taken years data traffic jumped by 10
percent that month more than in a year
working digitally from home was a huge
effort for many authorities and
companies but suddenly became the norm
but it wasn't all good news for Svenja
Schultz's environment ministry which
also says digitalization threatened
the climate in the search we've seen in
data traffic is just a sign of more to
come I'm not one of those who says
streaming will replace flying on the
contrary still we have to make progress
in all these areas if we really want to
meet our climate goals
hower in the internet is already
producing 800 million tons of co2
emissions worldwide each year that's
about as much as all of Germany or
worldwide air traffic before the crisis
but the overall environmental balance of
the coronavirus period has been positive
and that can teach us something about
upcoming crises says sociologists her
outfits are what it all shows us is that
change is possible much faster than we
have in normal politics where there are
always opposing sides
whenever you might think nothing works
but then you can see you can get things
done if there's a lot of political will
fear only in one area have things taken
an environmental step backwards in
Germany while public transport remains
as empty in many places as it was at the
beginning of the crisis roads have
filled up with private cars for fear of
infection people are driving more often
as much as before the crisis let's speak
to Philip fry who's part of the digital
technologies and social change research
group at the Institute for Technology
Assessment and systems analysis in
Karlsruhe here in Germany thanks for
joining us so all the changes we've seen
in working during the corona virus
pandemic a good approach for the long
term well to excited about the current
changes as they comment a terrible cost
but generally speaking I would say for
instance the reduction in commuting
hours or the reduction of business trips
is certainly something that is welcome
news to me but I would suggest that the
current crisis also challenges us more
to ask ourselves more fundamentally
whether we want to return to the old
normal or whether we want to
better towards a more socially and
ecologically sustainable economy you
talked about sure to work times you've
done research into this and you came up
with a figure of around 20 hours as
potentially an ideal working week that
would be a huge reduction for many
full-time workers around the world
what's the thinking behind that how do
you make that work well generally
there's a number of policy options at
hand I mean you can have a regulation on
a governmental level our national level
but also there's of course collective
bargaining instruments that can be used
to decrease working hours through
collective agreements basically and how
do you reduce working hours without
limiting productivity well that depends
what you mean by productivity actually
if you mean overall economic output then
I would say it might even be debatable
whether that's a sensible orientation in
the future given that we're already at
least in the global North consume way
too many resources it is but strength
generally there's also a strong economic
argument to be made for work and time
reductions actually oftentimes people
think that working time reductions are
something like a giveaway to workers in
the most productive economies so the
people in the US or in Germany are so
productive they can work a little less
but there's and there is a strong
correlation between higher productivity
and shorter working times
internationally but what I actually find
quite interesting is that researchers
suggest that collective working time
reductions force employers to use the
law but later time they have more
efficiently by reorganizing work and
introducing new technologies therefore
there's actually strong empirical
evidence that working time reductions
induce productivity growth but is there
a danger that's actually the corona
virus pandemic through increasing the
amount of working from home actually
means people are working longer I mean
we've heard from unions saying that's
exactly what is happening when people
are working from home yeah definitely a
risk I mean one thing that the humans
are keen to emphasize are is the
weakening barrier
between the private and professional
life which clearly plays a role but I
would say there's also a more general
threat because governments worldwide are
facing immense pressure from employer
associations to weaken existing labor
regulations and I think also individual
workers faced with a looming
unemployment crisis actually want to
show that there are dependable workers
and they want to save some money so they
work longer hours but I think we should
consider strongly whether we actually
want to have an economy where millions
are unemployed and many more millions
are working over hours and actually are
on the brink of collapse or burnout as
it is called and why do we want to just
distribute the work more equally
throughout society Philip fry from the
Institute for technology assessment and
systems analysis in Karlsruhe thanks for
joining us well now is the part of the
program where you get to ask the
questions to our science correspondent
Derek Williams what percentage of the
population has been infected in the
United States the number of confirmed
cases of kovat 19 in the u.s. at the
moment stands at over two and a half
million and the daily count is trending
upwards around around 40,000 new cases
join them every day then last week the
director of the country's Centers for
Disease Control hazard at a guess at a
statistic that lots of experts have been
trying to pin down ever since this
pandemic began the number of people who
get the disease that are never listed as
confirmed cases health care officials in
the u.s. now believe that only around 1
in 10 people in the u.s. who contract
kovat 19 are ever actually counted now I
think that we can view that as a pretty
rough estimate but but even if it is
just in the ballpark
it would mean around 20 million
Americans have or have already had
the disease is it true that people in
the old positive blood group are
resistant to covet 19 it's grown pretty
clear that blood type plays a role in
whether or not you might contract codon
19 several independent studies have
linked the blood group O both positive
and negative with resistance to
acquiring the virus and and also to less
severe outcomes one of the studies says
people with Type O are only 65% as
likely to be infected as others it's not
yet clear exactly why but since the
genes that determine blood type affect
surface structures on cells that could
be playing a preventive role and less
severe outcomes in people from the blood
group O might also be tied to the risk
of developing blood clots which is
different from blood type to blood type
[Music]
can you get Kovac 19 and the flu at the
same time yes people have tested
positive for both at the same time
although from the limited information we
have it doesn't appear to happen very
often
when it does doctors refer to the two
diseases as as Co infections
we also don't have much information on
what that kind of double whammy might
mean for the patient but but it seems
clear that having both respiratory
diseases at the same time would be a
pretty unpromising state of affairs and
when we know more it might turn out to
be more common that we think when
doctors start testing for both diseases
at once on a wide scale we might
discover that that's just one more
reason why it's important for as many
people as possible to get a flu shot
before the onset of flu season this fall
our science correspondent Derrick
Williams now for business people dealing
where the client oversees sometimes a
video conference simply won't do well
for those who simply must fly they can
at least get tested for coronavirus
during their trip Germany's first
Airport based test Center has just
opened in Frankfurt biotech company
Center gene is running it in cooperation
with airline Lufthansa and the airport
itself tested voluntary and have to be
paid for by the traveler themselves the
people behind it have caught it a
blueprint for the new normal of air trap